[Musique]
derrière sa grosse voix et ses airs
bougons jean pierre marielle a un goût
prononcé pour la mariole à 78 ans il
publie un abécédaire autobiographique
baptisé le grand n'importe quoi j'étais
aujourd'hui n'importe quoi à l'école on
lisait on me disait marié arrêter
n'importe quoi
après au conservatoire b mais qu'est ce
que vous faites l'amour et vous faites
n'importe quoi et puis maintenant quand
je tourne par exemple malgré mon grand
âge
j'entendais fois sur le plateau des gens
qui lisent vous allez remarquer il fait
n'importe quoi mais il fait n'importe
suis là je pense pas on m'appelle le
grand n'importe quoi et je le revendique
parce que c'est pas mal on se démarque
jean pierre marielle a toujours eu le
chic pour se distinguer il n'est
d'ailleurs le 12 avril 1932 avec une
moustache
tu ne dis pas presque nue je suis là et
kouakou stocks et j'avais déjà de la
barre moi je me suis rasé embrasait
quand j'étais encore joué
d'où mon berceau embrasé
marielle est bien un homme du terroir
profondément attaché à la terre élevé à
paris il garde un souvenir joyeux et
nostalgique de ses vacances passées en
bourgogne où les paysans prenait un
malin plaisir à le chèque
ah oui c'était des paysans gdsa vous
savez comment ils nous disaient avec
l'accent je vous le fais parisien groupe
b qu'allumer ton cul parisien foutu ça
je pense que ça vous le dire on n'était
plus celle qu'en bas quoique tu peux pas
les yéyés granby s'allume et aux stups
alesi a foutu c'est un professeur de
français rencontrés au lycée qui va
repérer ses talents de comédien il le
dissuade d'entrée en gagne et le pousse
à présenter le conservatoire jean pierre
marielle s'exécute
je suis allé au centre d'art dramatique
de la rue blanc je suis sorti avec un
prix je me suis présenté au
conservatoire j'étais pris hellemmes
j'ai été stages et à la comédie
française
j'ai commencé à jouer mon père a dit
c'est vraiment à retiers d'une facilité
incroyable
ses camarades du conservatoire s'appelle
jean paul belmondo jean rochefort bruno
cremer les filles se nomme annie
girardot ou françoise fabian
dans cette troupe de rêve aucune
obsession du vedettariat
mais une immense fraternité avec
belmondo ils se plaisent toujours à se
retrouver autour d'une bonne table on
déjeune ensemble comme ça puis on se met
à bavarder et oui je vis dans la classe
demain il pourrait me dire à quelle
heure il me le dit pas mais pour m me
dit on est resté encore on est encore au
conservatoire mais c'est normal on passe
longtemps au conservatoire trois quatre
ans les garçons et les filles qu'on a
rencontrés au conservatoire
quand on se retrouve on a le sentiment
de retrouver des gens de notre famille
marielle va aimer plus que tout le
théâtre mais jouera dans une centaine de
films jamais des rôles de jeunes
premiers toujours des hommes mûrs et de
toutes espèces en 50 ans de carrière il
est devenu un monstre sacré du cinéma
français
apparaissant dans les superproductions
américaines doré vous votre vie pour ce
secret budget comme vous voudrez attendu
ou un dieu vous donnez moi
on parle de l'aromatique bon mais moi je
suis un acteur un comédien mais je ne
suis pas un artiste je suis je fais je
fais mon boulot
[Musique]
pourtant il y un personnage dont jean
pierre marielle se sent proche un homme
qui lui ressemble et qui n'existe que
pour son art c'est le ster monsieur de
sainte colombe de tous les matins du
monde que le réalisateur alain corneau
lui offrit dans 91
[Musique]
moi je me suis mis merveilleusement
entendu et qu'alain corneau
a formidablement bien et puis le
personnage n'a pas plu il est rentré
comme ça on est à noter un peu envahis
par ce personnage vous voyez un
personnage très riche très mystérieux
comme ça et tu es c'était comme une
aventure mystérieuse
[Musique]
alain corneau est mort mais aussi bruno
cremer claude chabrol marielle arrive
vers des zones de moins en moins visité
ses amis disparaissent les uns après les
autres
moi je réponds c'est la guerre mettons
cas ce que c'est vrai oui combien [ __ ]
le camp
home assez rigolo de disparaître
c'est magnifique où est il il a dit ça
[Musique]